you have been critical of the policies
of the state of Israel but as we've
mentioned very supportive of Jewish
people you have a lot of friends rabbis
and
um Jews in general here in Dallas and
across the world
uh what is the difference to you in that
part of the world between politics and
religion so in this case Zionism and
Judaism uh both terms broadly defined
both terms broadly defined so I say that
because those terms
there's technical definitions and
there's how they're popularly used and
so you have to be kind of sure just like
we said with islamophobia these terms
are they become politicized so just
generally speaking I think Zionism
has to do with the with uh with politics
and Judaism has to do with the religion
it's a great complexity like to a lot of
people like wait a minute right and you
got to take a step back and wonder why
there are so many Zionist anti-semites
in America
and there are so many anti-zionists who
are far from being
anti-semites anti-zionism that are
opposed to the ideology that are opposed
to the implications of it
look uh I think that it's fundamentally
secular
um when you think about it there is an
ethno supremacism there is
I am the child of of Palestinians that
were forcibly displaced from their land
I've never been able to go to where my
parents my grandparents are from
I've never been able to see that land
I've never been able to access that I
have cousins that I'll never be well I
shouldn't say never inshallah God
willing I will need them but that I've
only been able to speak through a phone
face time zoom
um
I think that
it's important for us to separate
criticism of Israel's policies
from anti-Semitism in fact it's an
injustice
it cheapens anti-Semitism when you throw
every person who is opposed to Zionism
or opposed to Israel's policies in the
bucket of being anti-semites
it's it's wrong it cheapens it it
doesn't do justice to it
and I think it's important for us to
have a meaningful conversation about
America's support for Israel listen
there are terms
that are important here so I'm gonna
throw out these these big terms right
apartheid
occupation
ethnic cleansing these are terms that
are legal terms
there are objective thresholds here
for apartheid occupation ethnic
cleansing
the threshold of apartheid has been
crossed according to
multiple the most respectable human
rights organizations in the world these
are the organizations that you will
champion and that you will use and every
single other conflict to justify your
own policies
but that threshold of apartheid has been
passed according to Human Rights Watch
according to Amnesty International
according to the Harvard Law review
the threshold of apartheid has been
crossed there's a legal terminology
there two sets of laws for two separate
people you have a displaced people that
are forcibly
being removed that are being treated
differently that are stateless that are
undergoing daily humiliation that live
behind an apartheid wall that live under
a different set of policies that are
routinely bombarded that have lost their
ability to free movements that have lost
their ability to access to basic
necessities of human life there are
legal definitions here I don't see how
any objective human being can read those
reports on apartheid and the threshold
crossed for apartheid and walk away from
that and say that this is just Jews and
Muslims that don't like each other
there's a legal definition here
occupation
when Israel was created in 1948
you will find many Jews who are opposed
to Zionism and I think this is important
you know to talk to Jews who are opposed
to Zionism and they are many
uh that will say that we were told that
it was a land without a people
for a people without the lands the
problem with that was there were people
there
our ancestors 750 000 Palestinians
expelled in the nakaba and many
Palestinians that have been removed and
harassed and that are treated in
horrific ways and the occupation is
expanding it is in the legal occupation
the settlements are still expanding and
the United States enables that
occupation with its funding with its
unconditional support unwavering support
of Israel
and it does so in a way that completely
undermines any of its claims
to being a beacon of freedom of the in
the world because it is in plain sight
now that the world can see what is
happening what is happening in Jerusalem
what is happening with these expanding
settlements everything that flies in the
face of any claim to wanting a peaceful
solution the children in Gaza when I
talk about dehumanization the children
that were on the face of the New York
Times which is historically one of the
most anti-palestinian newspapers in
America the faces of the children of
Gaza
America
and many parts of the world are now
seeing it
we have been saying for a very long time
this is apartheid this is an occupation
this is an injustice the world needs to
check it hold it accountable
South Africa which experienced apartheid
Nelson Mandela Desmond Tutu all of those
that fought apartheid in South Africa
said that Palestinians are living under
apartheid and that the same strategies
that check apartheid in South Africa
need to be used to hold Israel
accountable for apartheid with the
Palestinians
it's impossible for us
as Palestinians
to Simply say
that we should give up on this cause
all the odds are stacked against us
but when you have you know videos coming
out of the Israeli armies you know
spewing skunk water
skunk water sewage water on worshipers
leaving in aksa
um
far-right leaders now taking the
government
and the so-called only democracy in the
Middle East prohibiting a Palestinian
flag being raised anywhere around
American reporters Serena
Palestinian American Christian reporter
palestine-american Christian reporter
one of the most prominent journalists in
the Middle East
shot in the face
Plain Sight
and All America could say was all the
American government could say was if it
turns out that it's indeed Israel that
Israel is responsible for the death of
an American journalists then we will
hold them accountable
nothing not a peep
it was a shame
to see that happen and it just
solidified to us that whether it's a
Democratic president or a Republican
president unfortunately the support for
Israel
is enabling it to continue to wipe out
the Palestinian population
from its historic lands and so
we see that happening and I'll say this
as well
people ask me about the Abraham Accords
I say you know you are
talking about faith between are you
talking about peace between communities
of faith and protecting communities of
Faith why are you opposed to the Abraham
Accords I think that the name of Abraham
should not be used and I wrote an
article called why I opposed the Abraham
Accords the name of Abraham should not
be used to justify arms deals that only
further disenfranchise the abused
population of the Palestinians where you
know you have quote unquote Muslim
regimes making peace with Israel and
that's being used against the
Palestinian people who are only further
disenfranchised from having a voice in
their own fate
for the sake of American Arms deals and
security and economic benefits
it's despicable it's repulsive talk to
the people
speak to people on the ground there see
what's happening with your own two eyes
and think about the Injustice where
our tax payer dollars are being used
to suppress a people and what legally
meets the definition by every objective
standard of apartheid of occupation of
ethnic cleansing and it's ongoing and
it's happening in real time and it's
becoming more blatant
with a regime now that's Unapologetic of
even expressing
what the policies have already done
and that is the removal of a people uh
forcible removal of a people because
the government knows that the United
States support is unconditional
give hope that Jews Muslims and
Christians in this land will
live in peace one day together
have a basic respect for each other's
Humanity
look
this isn't a religious conflict I think
that's fundamentally one of the problems
so even the question is not the correct
question it's not the correct question
this is not a religious conflict yes
religion is invoked yes there there are
religious elements
but
uh there are many Jews
that are opposed to what is happening
right now towards the Palestinians many
and I would I would recommend
you know serious discussion with even
people whose perspectives have grown
Peter bynart being an example
uh Rabbi Simone Zimmerman uh started if
not now
bait to slim an Israeli human rights
organization that also classed as
apartheid recently there are many Jews
that are opposed to what is happening
right now
Palestinians are also not exclusively a
Muslim population Sharina miracula was
Christian
there are many Palestinian Christians
that are also being denied entry into
their historic churches and that are
completely bewildered or or uh
absolutely lost in regards to why
American evangelicals have this Ironclad
support for the occupation and have
ignored the plight of Palestinian
Christians
of course I believe Muslims Christians
and Jews can coexist uh
of course I have hope because I have to
have hope as a person of faith
but as much hope as I have I think
there's a great sense of urgency for
people to open their eyes
learn what's actually happening on the
ground read the reports
stop letting these commentators and
these uh these companies that
are able to generate propaganda own the
narrative there are objective standards
here there are objective measures of
Oppression that need to be considered
here what's happening to Gaza is one of
the greatest atrocities of our time
learn about it right I tell people to
just watch the vice documentaries for
example the mini documentaries I'd sent
them to you as well inside the battle
for Jerusalem I mean think about it a
guy from Long Island New York
can fly to Israel
right
fly into Tel Aviv
and walk into a home that's been
occupied by families for generations and
throw the people out under the full
protection of the military there
and spit on them
historic homes
and when people come up to me and say
we're opposed to islamophobia where
post-islamophobia but they support that
I tell you're not opposed to
islamophobia how can you be opposed to
islamophobia when you
traffic in the same framings and
uh dehumanization
that enables the viciousness towards
Muslims here and Palestinians over there
that they do not deserve to be treated
like equal human beings like full human
beings and that based on historic claims
a guy can fly from New York into a
historic neighborhood in Jerusalem and
kick out generational families with
military guns next to them what does
that sound like how is that how's that
normal right and so I think that if
people take the time to read people take
the time to investigate
then they come to this conclusion
themselves that this is unacceptable
and that you can't put and this is one
of the problems with the framing of
israel-palestine is that you're equating
occupier and occupied you're equating
the two sides of the conflict and it's
not a conflict it's an occupation there
is such a disparity of power here
that you cannot equate the two sides how
you know you can't you know Malcolm X
would say you clip the bird's wing and
then fly and then blame it for not
flying as high as you do you can't you
can't do that to a people and just
equate them with their occupier it's an
atrocity it requires us to challenge it
and I'm hopeful at the current movement
of Muslims Christians and Jews and
people of all faiths that are saying
enough is enough that thresholds have
been crossed here that this this is an
atrocity that cannot continue you know
this is very personal to me because this
is happening now
what I anticipate and this is what
America did this is what Nelson Mandela
actually predicted with the United
States what I anticipate is that 10
years from now 20 years from now every
American will say how could we have
supported this
and this was terrible and will pay
symbolic you know homage to the
Palestinian cause
but there are people now that are
clinging on for dear life
access to their places of worship access
to their generational homes
right now at this very they're they're
children that are in detention and
there's a Bill in Congress to just stop
I mean
wherever you stand on this issue
child detainment
child detainment child detention
should be a red line right congresswoman
Betty McCullum has put this bill on the
floor of Congress he can't even get that
passed right just to just to at least
censure Child detainment by the IDF
so
people need to look into this deeper
they need to
consider the human element of this
and consider the urgency of it as well
with this new with this new regime it's
only going to unfortunately get get much
worse in the immediate term and so we
have to do something about it
if I may ask you for some advice for a
reason I'll explain maybe in a little
bit uh or maybe I should just explain
now which is I think
because you've talked about islamophobia
because you've been at the center of
so many catastrophic events because you
sort of jump into the fire uh to try to
help people you've been attacked a lot
just in general you've been under stress
it's just you're you're not immune to
stress so a part of me wants to ask
foreign
just how psychologically difficult it's
been and how where you draw strength
and would you advise if the opportunity
is there
for a person like me for silly kid in a
suit
to go to that part of the world and take
seriously conversations I would divide
it into two categories there's leaders
and there's people
the leaders are sort of these
uh political entities that have their
interests but they also have power
and they want to hold on to power and
then people are just regular people that
have families that just want to
um have basic rights and freedoms and
continue to love their families to
pursue different uh jobs and careers and
lives that they can flourish and so on
those are very kind of different
dynamics of play and if given the
opportunity to speak to leaders for me
would you advise I do it or not and when
I say leaders I mean leaders that
would make the case
the pro Zionist case
and the anti-sinus case and in both
cases I would make it a very challenging
conversations for both of them unlike
today our conversation today you're an
inspiring incredible person I'm a huge
fan of yours you've spread so much love
to the Muslim Community here to the
Jewish Community just everybody loves
you but uh not everybody none yes that's
true not everybody that's true but Harry
Potter a lot of people love you yes uh
but this was kind of an inspiring and a
positive conversation it wasn't very
challenging
now although we did tough touch
challenging topics and he did
exceptionally well there but I would do
very challenging conversation with those
leaders in that part of the world is
that a bad idea
all right well let me tell you from now
first and foremost the first part
because I don't want to lose the first
part of your your conversation is it
psychologically stressful very very
um
but when you're
when you're a person of faith and you
believe that
good work will always be rewarded
and that doing the right thing will
always be rewarded eventually
you're able to weather that storm
um
quite a bit
so your wife told you
um
right that's the second thing I was
going to mention is honestly supportive
a supportive family you know my dad's 80
man and he's been through a lot he was
born in 1943 before his five years
before Israel was even created he was
born in Palestine
he suffered displacement he has been
around the world and somehow built
himself up to be a distinguished
professor of chemistry an author an
inventor
um you know grew up uh taking on some of
the most difficult challenges and was
just always a man of principle I always
admired my dad being a man of principle
and like he just tells me man stay the
course stay the course Don't Be Afraid
don't back down
I have a supportive family I have a
supportive wife I've got supportive kids
so I have amazing people around me that
keep me grounded for sure and ultimately
obviously faith
and also I'll say this slander doesn't
stand what do you mean by that when
people slander you and it kind of comes
with the territory of a public figure
um it's not going to stand throughout
time because eventually any sincere
person will find the truth
and the only people that will
regurgitate that will continue to do so
so when I get portrayed as
an anti-semite
um
because of my strong takes on Israel and
challenging Israel and then I and I will
continue to do so
it takes just people in gosh like we
know him what are you talking about you
know so slander doesn't stand at least
with the people that are important to
you it might reside on the internet it
might have great rankings and social
media Bots that give attraction but also
psychologically difficulty of course yes
it is difficult it's very difficult and
it's hurtful especially when it comes
from quarters that you would hope that
it doesn't come from
but you know you take a step back you
re-evaluate you lean into your faith and
you lean on the people that are closest
to you and then you keep going
you learned the lessons uh could I be
doing something better could I be doing
something different could I be saying
something better could I be saying
something different are the noble causes
that I want to achieve am I am I doing
Justice by those causes uh how do I grow
out of this right you become wiser
through these things as well
second part of your question though
about what you should do if you're going
to talk to people talk to people
from a place of inquiry I would say talk
to people more so than leaders and
especially some of those who have been
erased from the com from the media
commentary Benjamin Netanyahu gets a lot
of air time
uh you know here in the United States
um he's uh
well spoken you know he speaks perfect
English he's an American as well
um I would challenge him you know on on
some of the things that he has said and
done uh he has an ongoing corruption
case I I think that
um I think he's a fascist I think that
he's a a person who has done much evil I
think that he has a lot of blood on his
hands and I think that one day he will
be prosecuted for that
uh but I'd say talk to people on the
ground
and people that have been erased talk to
the families that are being displaced I
don't care about the political
leadership I'd much rather you talk to
the people on the ground in East
Jerusalem that have been displaced
um the families talk to Palestinian
Christians talk to the sister of Sharina
bakla Lina Lina abacla who has been who
was extremely disappointed and let down
when Joe Biden went to the region and
did not take her calls did not meet her
which was an absolutely disgraceful move
he should have met with her uh she's the
sister of an American journalist who was
murdered in Cold Blood uh talked to Lena
talked to Mitri Rahat Mitri uh
interesting person for example he's a
Lutheran he's the head of the Lutheran
Church in Palestine he comes to Dallas
sometimes and talks about the plight of
Palestinian Christians uh I think if
you're talking to people in leadership
you know obviously there are some that
will be able to represent themselves in
English
as a very eloquent person for example
I don't know if you're going to have any
luck getting into Gaza but I'll pray for
you if you do but obviously you know if
you want to talk to everybody you got to
talk to everybody man so well and I also
want to say this very important when you
say whitewashing because I've heard this
a lot so also Ukraine and Russia there's
an interesting line between whitewashing
which is something you definitely should
not do and a deep empathy
for
a large number of human beings it's a
it's a really tricky line to walk and I
also disagree with you about well I
think I don't know if it's a
disagreement but I think I disagree
about leaders I think I agree 100 that
the most important people are the people
on the ground okay but
I think those are extremely important
people to understand not just as Leaders
but as human beings too
and in many cases to have a challenging
conversation but from a place of empathy
from understanding a human being so if
you plan to talk to right wing the
current leadership of Israel
my only request to you
is talk to the victims themselves not
the Palestinian Authority talk to the
victim I know you want to right so I and
I appreciate them yes to the victims
themselves talk to those people that are
being thrown out of their homes and
subjected to the Daily humiliation go to
a checkpoint and walk through the
checkpoint the way that a Palestinian
walks through a checkpoint and tell me
that's not apartheid walk through that
checkpoint crammed in in cages and tell
me it's not apartheid so uh I think
you're a very sincere person uh I think
you're gonna you're gonna do your best
uh I'll be praying for you some of these
such things are harder than others but
yes I feel like we're in the middle of a
negotiation and we've come to a point
where we both agree everyone deserves to
be everyone not everyone deserves to be
but I think there's Great Value and
benefit I let me say I agree with you
and and hearing people even uh tyrants
um hearing them so that you can properly
deconstruct and decipher what you're
hearing but just think of the voices
that don't get hurt third and a lot of
times what's been done to the Muslim
world is and what's being done right now
in the name of the Abraham Accords
what's wrong with the Palestinians
the other Arabs are making peace with
them let me tell you something those
regimes that are signing on to the
Abraham Accords the people are not happy
but they're terrified
of challenging those regimes so if you
go talk to the leaders of some of these
countries that have signed on to the
Abraham Accords
and that are you know in some Twisted
way
um making this about religion and peace
you can greatly skew
the narrative
to where Palestinians are just an
inherently disagreeable people that
don't want peace
they just want to live in their homes
they just want to live as full equal
human beings they want the things that
everybody everybody wants
and they're only being further
disenfranchised in the name of peace now
because voices are being Amplified
in the name of peace that are
suffocating voices for justice